Hi my name is Pedram Mokrian. I'm an Adjunct
Professor here at Stanford School of Engineering.
This course is designed for people that are
looking to get a better perspective on what
exactly AI is about and demystify some of these
notions in terms of what is machine learning,
how is it different from AI, what are some of
the applications, where is the future going.
We're going to begin with taking a historical
view of AI, a very high level view of the
technologies, how are we actually applying this AI
infrastructure and advancements in the technology
that we're getting into business outcomes. We're
going to try to bring this all together by giving
you an idea of how to think more strategically
about how do you actually put in place an AI
strategy as part of an existing product or
actually creating an entirely new product
line or service line that's centered around AI.
Joining me are going to be a myriad of folks
that are coming from industry themselves with a
depth of background and artificial intelligence
that is world-class. You have large amounts
of data that these machines will be able to,
given our guidance, run through very quickly
find the patterns, find the signals, and start to
create potentially either better products for you
or new products for you. And that's really what's
driving almost all of the the data-driven business
strategies now is is going out and getting data
rather than commodity analytics.
We've built a lot of infrastructure,
whether by technology or by policy, in
order to manage just the data aspect of it
before we even start looking at it from an AI
algorithm what can we learn from a perspective.
So we're really really excited to be able
to share some of these insights with you
and we're excited to get this course underway.